Recall that we have at least two ways in which we can deal with your stressful
situations. One, is problem focus coping and the other is emotion focus coping.
Recall that with problem focused coping, we looked for strategies to solve the
problem and therefore, reduce our stress. With emotion focus coping, we look at
ways in which we can reduce the negative emotional response that we experience
to stress. Now, we discussed a variety of emotion-focused coping responses.
Social support is one way in which we can reduce the negative emotional
responses that we feel in regards to stress. Therefore, talking with friends or
family about stressful situations or predicaments in which we find ourselves,
can go a long way in reducing our overall stress levels. This in turn we know
is important for our overall brain health and immune system functioning.
Therefore, we want to avoid long term exposure to stress because we know
cortisol has a negative effect on the hippocampus and our immune system
functioning. Now, we're going to move on and see how stress affects our health,
and Greg's going to introduce that topic for us.